les dernières grappes de raisins sont
récoltés
le sprint final d'un long marathon une
course au cours de laquelle les
viticulteurs néo écossais veulent
réduire leur empreinte carbone
des panneaux solaires ont poussé aux
côtés des vignes de style veuf il
alimente les haut parleurs qui
repoussent les oiseaux et
les clôtures électriques qui éloigne les
ratons laveurs du nombre d'allers
retours des camions à la quantité de
pesticides
chaque juste pour aider la planète et
réfléchie et calculer
les feuilles de vie sont réutilisés pour
couvrir le sol
la culture de couverture vise à produire
de la biomasse et réduire les mauvaises
herbes des 20 hectares de vignes
cultivés ici et dont les raisins sont
vendus à un vignoble
le benjam enbridge aussi en quête de
carboneutralité
[Musique]
il y a 4 1 avant même les stars du
prêt-à-boire le vignoble a lancé une
première gamme de produits en canette la
préoccupation environnementale a guidé
ce choix le verre souvent fabriqués en
europe ou en asie est lourd à
transporter l'aluminium se recycle le
mieux est compatible avec les bains
rafraîchissant de belgium enbridge
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
l'aluminium est intéressant comme
comme alternative le qui est à notre
portée à l'heure actuelle quelque chose
qu'on peut faire le tout de suite selon
michel bouffard autrice du lit qu'elle
vaille pour demain le conditionnement
représente avec le transport les deux
plus importantes sources de pollution
l'industrie voûté y aller j'irai
beaucoup moins d'empreinte carbone
ensuite on peut choisir même des
conditionnements alternatifs les
produits en canette se sont multipliés
chez benjam enbridge et on envisage
maintenant un autre type d'emballage lui
aussi plus écologique que le verre le
vigne est en fait c'est appelé à revenir
ce
niveau c'est le jeu demain partisans
naturel
dans la vigne et bendahmane bridge
encore une fois c'est dans c'est à l'âge
aidant c'est à l'ordre du jour
[Musique]
all that i have signé le vignes et a
longtemps été associé à des produits bas
de gamme la tendance pourrait s'inverser
on a vu dernièrement des producteurs
qualitatif commencé à mettre des vins
vignes et donc j'espère que les vins
canadiens vont suivre le sale et on pose
pas que ça c'est du pinot noir en blanc
de noir comme ça qui a été pressé au
rider surprend ce couple de québécois en
visite dans la vallée d'annapolis qui
fait on élimine la bouteille on aimait
le processus de 20
ce sera une adaptation aussi un moyen de
le faire clair pour voir un peu le
produit le charme la couleur la robe
avant de l'avoir dans son verre je pense
que ce serait peut-être une belle option
mais si steve hayes veut imiter son père
de 87 ans loin de ce tourbillon de vidéo
immersive prenez youth and et travailler
dans ses vignes aussi longtemps des
virages surprenant devront faire partie
de l'histoire ici mme montembeault
radio-canada canning